مسيرتان بدولار واحد فقط عرض امريكي
لاوكرانيا لمساعده الاخيره بالدفاع عن
نفسها في الوقت الذي تستعد فيه لهجوم روسي
متوقع قبيل الربيع المقبل فوفقا ان لويس
ستريت الامريكيه شركات جنرال اتومكس
الامريكيه التي تعتبر من اكبر الشركات
للصناعات العسكريه في العالم عرضت على
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه بيع كل طائرتين
من دون طيار من طراز ام كيو 9 ريبر مقابل
الدولار واحد الصفقه ستطلب منك انفاق
حوالي 10 ملايين دولار لاعاده وشحن
الطائرات الى اوكرانيا وحوالي ثمانيه
ملايين دولار الى لكل عام لصيانه هذه
الطائرات من دون طبعا طيار القديمه والتي
لا يتم استخدامها حاليا في اوكرانيا العرض
يشمل ايضا محطه تحكم ارضيه لتشغيل
الطائرات من دون طيار في اي مكان على
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وفقا لرساله
الصحيفه الامريكيه انها طلعت عليها مسيرات
هي ريبر ليست مسلحه ولكن يمكن حملها في
حقيبه على الظهر وتستخدم لتصطدم بالاهداف
يبلغ حول طول جناحي ريبير حوالي 66 قدما
ويمكن تصليحها كما يمكنها ايضا ان تطير
لاكثر من اربعه وعشرين ساعه البيت الابيض
الذي سيتعين عليه الموافقه على صفقه البيع
رفضت تعليق على الامر حتى الان وعاشنتا
كانت قد قدمت في العام الماضي اكثر من 700
طائره من دون طيار اصغر الى اوكرانيا بما
في ذلك طائرات من دون طيار تكتيكيه من
طراز
[موسيقى]